all right so hi everyone let's start
with a quick poll how many people here
are user researchers and got a couple
how many people here come from companies
who have user researchers okay there's a
good for you of you that's nice okay so
I'm sure that you heard earlier from
some of the talks today that improving
the quality of your app is a really
great way to boost the star rating or
your use of retention many to the
earlier talks today you know spoke to
that you would have heard Ricardo and
Alexei talk about how app quality was
really important and how you can use
android vitals to improve the quality of
your app after launch but what I want to
talk to you about today is the process
that informs all of that the process
that helps you ship a high-quality app
in the first place
so rather than kind of going with your
gut and go into the market open for the
best this is about using user research
to make sure that the decisions you make
are sort of as useful objective and as
sensible as they possibly can be so how
do you do that we all know that building
a product in a vacuum is really not a
great way to create products that users
love so as user researchers on the
Google Play team it's her job to help
the product teams curry experiences that
are useful usable and desirable or even
magical for our users so what I want to
talk to you today is about how to make
the research you're doing impactful and
the real key to doing impactful research
is not some silver bullet method it's
not some fancy piece of kit it's not
necessarily some really complex process
the real key to doing impactful research
is making sure you get the most out of
the research you do and making sure that
that research case you used in some way
so this talk is really just about some
insanely practical methods and
techniques that will help you go away
and do better use of research and your
product is going to be better because of
it this is about whatever you're doing
right now and making sure that that
investment pays off if you get this
right everything else gets easier okay
so how do you do impactful research what
is that so I'm going to share with you
today three mistakes that we can of
commonly see people make when
approaching doing user research and
three methods and techniques from my
experience as a research or in the
Google Play team to help you mitigate
that risk and to make the research you
do more impactful
so the mistakes using the wrong methods
at the wrong time separating the
research from the rest of this team and
asking the wrong questions have fairly
straightforward fixes but fixing them
will help you maximize the value of the
research you do and make the most of the
data you collect in order to make better
decisions okay so mistake number one
using the wrong methods at the wrong
time so research is really just about
asking good questions and depending on
where you are in the product lifecycle
you probably have different questions
that need answered we can a makes sense
right so as your product or feature
evolve so do the cane of questions you
need to ask but one mistake we commonly
see is people trying to ask either the
same questions again and again as their
product evolved or trying to answer
different questions with the same
methods that really don't fit so doing
impactful research is not just about
using impactful methods it's really
about picking the right methods for the
questions you have and asking the right
questions at the right time so on my
team when we think about doing user
research we start by thinking we're
about in the development process we are
and typically at a high level there's
only really three questions that we need
to answer the first one is what to build
hmm the second one is how to build it
and the third one is did we succeed and
we call this strategic user research
design user research and the value to
user research so each of these questions
has many many many different methods you
can use and picking the right method is
going to help you maximize how useful
that answer is to you
there's robably too many methods to each
days that I can cover in this talk but
let me walk you through some of this
stuff that we do on Google Play
highlighting the kind of research we do
at each stage okay so the first question
we do or the first question we ask is
what to build this is kind of strategic
user research really the goal here is to
help inform the product direction and
uncover new opportunities so what kind
of research can you do at this stage
what message can you do it to help you
use this so one of our most powerful
tools for this on both the developer
side and on the consumer side are what
we call kind of immersion or
observational studies and this is really
just basically watching people
use your product or feature
understanding what they're doing and
really asking them why they're doing
what they're doing already the method is
really just watching your users and
asking them why at this stage in the
process the goal is to discover things
you don't already know and to deep dive
into topics that really matter to your
users some of you may recognize my
colleague Phil here is a researcher on
the Play console team he does a lot of
these kind of studies with developers so
what is the method here how do you make
the most of these observational studies
it could really be as simple as just
sitting down with a bunch of your users
getting them to show you them using your
product or feature and just watching
them do it asking them why they're doing
it here's some few techniques that can
help you make the most out of those
sessions the first one is not to ask
leading questions this is something we
see people do all the time when we
invade sort of product arrange into
these sessions we see them asking
questions for the answer do they want to
hear is kind of embedded in the question
that they're asking so that's a really
obvious one don't do that the second one
is not really to ask questions it can be
answered with a yes or no answer this is
something else that we really commonly
see like do you want feature a or B yes
or no this is not great as it really
doesn't get you very rich data you get
one data point if you ask questions that
are more open-ended and encourage your
users to talk you'll really get much
richer data out of them the last thing
that we see people do is kind of drawing
attention to specific things that they
really care about this is bad as well as
it tends to change users behavior when
you're talking to them so don't draw
attention to things like features or
particular interface elements that you
do that you cannot want to know about
you want to see if users talk about them
naturally or see if they're noticing
them at all so observing your users in
this way and kind of understanding why
they're doing what they're doing is a
really great way to kind of uncover new
opportunities and kind of gay the
strategic direction of your product okay
so now you can have an idea of what to
build the next question we ask is how
you build it this is the stage where
you're trying to explore design concepts
and try to converge somehow to an ideal
solution so what research methods can
you use here so method that we'd really
like that helps us support design
solutions really quickly is something to
be called seer a seer a is a version of
traditional sort of rapid
of testing and evaluates of methodology
but it ensures cross-disciplinary
collaboration on planning and executing
the research so see right builds on a
traditional right methodology during
which designs are evaluated in the agile
user centered framework and in race
studies multiple stakeholders
collaborate in order to iteratively
build and test prototypes but in these
race that these stakeholders usually
have to commit to maybe one or two weeks
of involvement which can be challenging
with Seawright addresses this by
reducing the collaboration effort to the
two and a half days a week and in that
time the same problems are researched
and new ideas are designed forum
prototypes with Seawright you can kind
of go from research to new design in one
day and key stakeholders collaborate and
all UX phases so what are the strengths
here why is this good the first one is
that you get the entire team engaged in
the process and I'm going to talk about
this more later but that's a really key
thing to making your research you do
useful the second thing is it allows
really really quick iteration so the
research and says that you get are used
almost immediately which ensures that
they're going to be impactful down to
the product to your building
stakeholders are highly motivated who
are with the opportunity to express
opinions about what they've just
observed in the research sessions which
we find is a great kind of motivator for
people and as the product over and be
able to listen to and kind of engage in
discussions with all stakeholders really
creates really rich can have design
discussions so the key here with CRA is
more that the insights are used
immediately and the whole team are
involved in the process that's a really
key thing from making this research
YouTube impactful ok so that's an
example of how you can figure out what
to build and put yourself in a good
position to know that you're building
the right thing so the next question we
asked is did we succeed served by this
point in the research you're probably in
a great position you're confident that
your product is serving some Kennan
needs and you've kind of ironed out all
the usability creases and have about all
the usability issues during can of c
write tests so here you don't
necessarily need to do anything complex
you really just need to pick whatever it
is you measure and care about and
measure to see if it's gone up
you're basically but in its simplest
form you're basically just asking did we
succeed you can do this with your
analytics or engagement data you can do
this
user satisfaction and you're basically
just trying to understand if users are
engaged with and satisfied with the
product you build okay so we covered a
bunch of different research methods you
can use each stage in this process and
as I said before each method has or each
question has many different methods that
you can use much more than I have a
chance to cover in this talk but
hopefully we can kind of give you a
flavor of how you can use different
research methods at each stage but the
key here is that picking the right
methods to use at the right time
or maximize how useful that is the
answer is to you and then maximize the
impact of that research is going to have
on your product using the wrong method
at the wrong time can make the research
you do more difficult and the other key
thing with this is the better job you do
answering each of these questions
successfully reduces the amount of work
you have to do each stage so if you do
really good strategic research you can
go into your design research knowing
that the product you're building is
really serving a need you do really good
design research you can go to market
knowing that the usability and design
creases are a lie on down and then you
really just have to measure in the
evaluative stage okay so mistake number
two separating research from the rest of
the team serve among researchers is
common to here research can have been
treated as a separate unit or can have
detached from the rest of the product
and ange teams and in that case for the
product lens teams to become
disconnected from the research that's
happening so it's really is key and
these four situations is kind of easy
for the research teams and the product
teams to fall out of sync and more
likely that the research that gets done
either isn't timely or doesn't answer
key questions so the thing that we do
here is really to try and make the
methods we use as collaborative as
possible you want your team members to
feel ownership over the results so good
product research isn't really about an
academic ivory tower
you don't want research to feel like
it's being handed down for above I worth
the product team and collaboration is a
huge part of avoiding that disconnect if
you get people involved in the research
the research will be more valuable and
then it's more likely to be used so this
is an example picture of the Play
console team on a sort of research trip
research and merchants trip a couple
years ago here we have designer and
and BT product manager Biddy and frog
manager and researcher all out together
around Tripp go in to visit users and to
listen to their problems and try to
figure out product strategy and decide
where to go so why is this good
involving the team is really valuable
for multiple reasons not only did they
get a first-hand say of the end force
and sense of the N size team members we
get to meet face to face with users
there's lots of cross-functional
collaboration which is really good for a
really good at hand sense of team so
this was a quote from one of the
engineers who participated in the study
so these studies are great and the
feedback is invaluable I hope we can set
up some direct or some continuous direct
communication with developers in
addition to these regular studies we
find that it's really good for engineers
to be able to have first-hand contact
with their users as well as it really
makes you feel good knowing that you're
building something that's making a
difference to someone's life okay so
we've covered when to do research and
some of the techniques you can use to
increase the value of your research
every stage so finally I want to share
some kind of techniques that you can do
to help focus your research on topics
that you know are going to be impactful
so as I said before good research is
really about asking good questions
there's no point in kind of asking the
same question again and again there's no
point in asking questions that you don't
necessarily need the answer to and
there's no point in asking too many
questions that you collect too much data
that then you can't action all of it so
in the Play console teaming on the play
team in general we have a whole team of
researchers that can help with this we
have experts and trying to decide what
researchers needs to be done and what
doesn't and how to decide which
questions are most valuable and really a
key thing like if you want to be able to
do invite for research a really good
thing to do is to hire good user
researchers if you're not going to be
able to learn how to code or learn how
to product manage from a 20 minute talk
but if you don't have that and you don't
have a dedicated resource and you're
trying to decide where you should invest
in research how can you do that so a
good way to do this is to be looking at
the reviews analysis section on the
Google Play console this is a great
technique to uncover topics where you
can improve your app based on the star
rating or compared to
your competitors the topic analysis
itself won't tell you how to improve
something but it will let you gave the
research you do to areas where you know
you can have impact so you can look for
areas where you need to understand more
why are lots of my bad reviews
associated with the topic profile you
can find areas where you want to improve
your star rating and you can find areas
where you can improve compared to your
competitors as I said this is a great
way to direct research to areas that can
have real impact to your app so how do
you do that
so in this section you can see how users
of your app compared to a bunch of
common topics against most of the
similar apps in the same place tour
category issue so these common topics
can include things like design profile
resource usage speed etc so I'm going to
walk through a few examples of how you
may do research if you come across some
kind of if you found that these topics
we're having a negative effect on your
rating in some way so as I discussed
earlier taking deep dives into things
that really matter to your users is one
of the goals of doing strategic research
so it's a great time to understand why
certain topics if you don't know why are
pulling down your rating so you can use
some of the reasons listed in the
reviews again something like resource
usage or uninstalls to understand why
your users are unhappy with those things
the chances are if people have wrote
reviews about it there'll be something
the users who participate in your
research will have opinions on as well
and the real key here is to understand
what the expectations were and whether
or not they were met or on met for
design usability this is a great time to
use something like Siri again so you
want to explore design issues you want
to explore usability and kind of explore
new design solutions and again you can
use the topics mentioned than the
individual reviews to help guide the
actual research and then to deep dive
even further into topics that are really
specific for your app you can look at
those really detailed topics that come
out of your reviews so the news eases
probes in your research and reviews to
really understand why users are talking
about really things that are very
particular
you're not okay so what do I want you to
take away from this talk so doing
impactful research is not just about
some silver bullet impactful methods
it's really about picking the right
method to use at the right time in your
development process to answer impactful
questions that are going to be useful
for your whole team and as I said before
if you really want to invest in good
impactful research then it's really
great to look go and find good use of
researchers to hire and join your team
we're really nice people actually good
honestly but if you can't do that or if
you don't have enough user research
capacity just know I hope that you'll
find the kind of simple methods and
techniques in this talk useful for going
away to do research that can help you
make your product or app much better
thank you
you